[Applause]
welcome this month to the presidency to
resist the clips of the star go to
josiane to all and must form
debt securities a man who like to go 100
miles and where is because he loves the
guardian a little weight  black boots
from the second bang to
villa stein
rating 5/10 mouthe de mouthe doubs eve
with this wood china respect
mitch and janis joplin drm weather will be
windy provincial molasses she's
a hard worker cues prazuck like i
said i don't  I'm not the man for goodbyes
I sometimes cry I've already
cried a lot and that's enough
but I would like to tell you that I leave
the head of the committee
with two elements rate of satisfaction
with a few many regrets but I
am happy to  leave because being
president of the commission
is not an easy task
someone offered a book two years ago of
moosch different job of the wat and
I said to myself here it must be a
secretary  e general of the UN but in fact
we deliver it I discover that it was the
gray member of the commission who was targeted
by this somewhat pompous registration of
200 euros I really liked
working with the press
I no longer know the  number of appointments
that we had there are many
18 greece conferences in this room
150 someone
70 press conference in the
common vip 150 interviews and so I know
that I have put you to work farther
than you would have liked  but I don't
think that speaking has an influence
when it becomes rare if we repeat
ourselves jacques every day if we this site is
even every day what I like to do
because I find all the same to have been
able to enter a language that  was quite
understandable in how it pissed off
the others so I wanted to
thank you for this long road that
we did together raptor
died of a sport they say we are going
but I keep repeating that shaft yes but
the German is becoming rarer
I  v  think that no one can escape it and
amortization of the south is negative
joke president danny stas luxembourg
and those of standard of living of the classes
work
the internship before 10 boarding schools organized ten
unique linguistic erased
need them the fus which corresponds to a
crazy speed  to assume my two flashes
if you must be the sons of our
dance but I did not I give I say
that I have always said that the euro and
myself I believe that minal hominal has
challenged is I always confuse the two
from her because all mambo text lessons
even to the same degree is what
i was trying to pick my choices frankly i still don't know
what language joseph
if we speak multiple languages ​​never know
what bounce rive is in
any  way i'm too stupid to
respond to blows and memories of
dreams that couldn't be mine
by the way was pretty nice to see
that dreams aren't subject to the
dictatorship of transparency
I have often said that the hero and
I were the only survivors of the
crash test the euro will be alone I take
qualification